foreign
[Music]
s to racial and sexual and religious
chauvinism to rabid nationalist fervor
are beginning not to work because of who
I am and whether I'm good or bad or a
achieving or not all that's learned
along the way it's just a ride
we can change it anytime we want it's
only a choice no effort no work no job
no Savings of money you realize that I
had the game wrong
that the game was to find out what I
already was
foreign
[Music]
we were saying
how very important it is
to bring about in the human mind
the radical revolution
the crisis
is a crisis in consciousness
[Music]
a crisis
that
cannot anymore
accept the old norms
the old patterns
the ancient traditions
and
considering
what the world is now
with all the misery
conflict
destructive brutality
aggression
and so on
man
he still as he was
still brutal violent aggressive
acquisitive competitive
and he is built a society
along these lines
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
society today is composed of a series of
institutions
from political institutions legal
institutions religious institutions
to institutions of social class familial
values and occupational specialization
it is obvious the profound influence
these traditionalized structures have in
shaping our understandings and
perspectives
yet of all the social institutions we
are born into directed by and
conditioned upon there seems to be no
system is taken for granted and
misunderstood as the monetary system
taking on nearly religious proportions
the established monetary institution
exists as one of the most unquestioned
forms of Faith there is
how money is created
the policies by which it is governed and
how it truly affects Society our
unregistered interests of the great
majority of the population
in a world where one percent of the
population owns 40 percent of the
planet's wealth in a world where 34 000
children die every single day from
poverty and preventable diseases and
where 50 percent of the world's
population lives on less than two
dollars a day one thing is clear
something is very wrong
and whether we are aware of it or not
the lifeblood of all of our established
institutions and thus Society itself is
money
therefore understanding this institution
of monetary policy is critical to
understanding why our lives are the way
they are
unfortunately economics is often viewed
with confusion in boredom endless
streams of financial jargon coupled with
intimidating mathematics quickly deters
people from attempts at understanding it
however the fact is the complexity
associated with the financial system is
a mere mask designed to conceal one of
the most socially paralyzing structures
Humanity has ever endured
foreign
a number of years ago the Central Bank
of the United States the Federal Reserve
produced a document entitled modern
money mechanics this publication
detailed the institutionalized practice
of money creation as utilized by the
Federal Reserve and the web of global
commercial Banks it supports on the
opening page the document states its
objective the purpose of this booklet is
to describe the basic process of money
Creation in a fractional Reserve banking
system it then proceeds to describe this
fractional Reserve process through
various banking terminology
a translation of which goes something
like this
the United States government decides it
needs some money so it calls up the
Federal Reserve and requests say 10
billion dollars the FED replies saying
sure we'll buy 10 billion in government
bonds from you so the government takes
some pieces of paper paints some
official looking designs on them and
calls them treasury bonds then it puts a
value on these bonds to the sum of 10
billion dollars and sends them over to
the Fed
in turn the people at the FED draw up a
bunch of impressive pieces of paper
themselves only this time calling them
Federal Reserve notes also designated a
value of 10 billion dollars to the set
the FED then takes these notes and
trades them for the bonds once this
exchange is complete the government then
takes the 10 billion in Federal Reserve
notes and deposits it into a bank
account and upon this deposit the paper
notes officially become legal tender
money adding 10 billion to the U.S money
supply and there it is 10 billion in new
money has been created
of course this example is a
generalization for in reality this
transaction would occur electronically
with no paper used at all in fact only
three percent of the U.S money supply
exists in physical currency the other 97
percent essentially exists in computers
alone
now government bonds are by Design
instruments of debt and when the FED
purchases these bonds with money it
essentially created at a thin air the
government is actually promising to pay
back that money to the Fed
in other words the money was created out
of debt
this mind-numbing Paradox of how money
or value can be created out of debt or a
liability will become more clear as we
further this exercise
so the exchange has been made and now 10
billion dollars sits in a commercial
bank account here's where it gets really
interesting for is based on the
fractional Reserve practice that 10
billion dollar deposit instantly becomes
part of the bank's reserves just as all
deposits do
and regarding reserve requirements as
stated in modern money mechanics
a bank must maintain legally required
reserves equal to a prescribed
percentage of its deposits it then
quantifies this by stating under current
regulations the reserve requirement
against most transaction accounts is 10
percent
this means that with a 10 billion dollar
deposit 10 or 1 billion is held as the
required Reserve while the other 9
billion is considered an excessive
reserve and can be used as the basis for
new loans
now it is logical to assume that this 9
billion is literally coming out of the
existing 10 billion dollar deposit
however this is actually not the case
what really happens is that the 9
billion is simply created out of thin
air on top of the existing 10 billion
deposit this is how the money supply is
expanded
as stated in modern money mechanics of
course they the banks do not really pay
out loans from the money they receive as
deposits if they did this no additional
money would be created what they do when
they make loans is to accept promissory
notes loan contracts in exchange for
credits money to the borrowers
transaction accounts in other words the
9 billion can be created out of nothing
simply because there is a demand for
such a loan and that there is a 10
billion dollar deposit to satisfy the
reserve requirements
now let's assume that somebody walks
into this bank and borrows the newly
available nine billion dollars they will
then most likely take that money and
deposit it into their own bank account
the process then repeats for that
deposit becomes part of the bank's
reserves 10 is isolated and in turn 90
percent of the 9 billion or 8.1 billion
is now available as newly created money
for more loans and of course that 8.1
can be loaned out and redeposited
creating an additional 7.2 billion
to 6.5 billion
to 5.9 billion Etc
this deposit money creation loan cycle
can technically go on to Infinity the
average mathematical result is that
about 90 billion dollars can be created
on top of the original 10 billion
in other words for every deposit that
ever occurs in the banking system about
nine times that amount can be created
out of thin air
money Jitters ask the obliging Bank of
America for a jar of soothing instant
bunny
m-o-n-e-y in the form of a convenient
personal loan
so now that we understand how money is
created by this fractional Reserve
banking system a logical yet elusive
question might come to mind
what is actually giving this newly
created money value the answer the money
that already exists
the new money essentially steals value
from the existing money supply
for the total pool of money is being
increased irrespective to demand for
goods and services and as supply and
demand finds equilibrium prices rise
diminishing the purchasing power of each
individual dollar
this is generally referred to as
inflation and inflation is essentially a
hidden tax on the public
what is the advice that you generally
get and that is inflate the currency
they don't say debase the currency they
don't say devalue the currency they
don't say cheat the people who are saved
they say lower the interest rates the
real deception is when we distort the
value of money when we create money out
of thin air we have no savings yet
there's so-called Capital so my question
boils down to this how in the world can
we expect to solve the problems of
inflation that is the increase in the
supply money with more inflation of
course it can't the fractional Reserve
System of monetary expansion is
inherently inflationary for the act of
expanding the money supply without there
being a proportional expansion of goods
and services in the economy will always
debase a currency in fact a quick glance
at the Historical values of the US
dollar versus the money supply reflects
this point definitively for the inverse
relationship is obvious
one dollar in 1913 required 21.60 in
2007 to match value
that is a 96 devaluation since the
Federal Reserve came into existence
[Music]
now if this reality of inherent and
Perpetual inflation seems absurd and
economically self-defeating hold that
thought
for absurdity is an understatement in
regard to how our financial system
really operates
for in our financial system money is
debt
and debt is money
here is a chart of the U.S money supply
from 1950 to 2006.
here is a chart of the U.S national debt
for the same period how interesting it
is that the trends are virtually the
same
for the more money there is the more
debt there is the more debt there is the
more money there is
to put it a different way every single
Dollar in your wallet is owed to
somebody by somebody for remember the
only way the money can come into
existence is from loans therefore if
everyone in the country were able to pay
off all debts including the government
there would not be one dollar in
circulation
in fact the last time in American
history the national debt was completely
paid off was in 1835 after President
Andrew Jackson shut down the central
bank that proceeded the Federal Reserve
in fact Jackson's entire political
platform essentially revolved around his
commitment to shut down the Central Bank
stating at one point the Bold efforts
the present bank has made to control the
government are but premonitions of the
Fate that awaits the American people
should they be deluded into a
perpetuation of this institution or the
establishment of another lichen
unfortunately his message was
short-lived and the international
Bankers succeeded to install another
Central Bank in 1913. the Federal
Reserve and as long as this institution
exists
Perpetual debt is guaranteed
now so far we have discussed the reality
that money is created out of debt
through loans these loans are Based On A
bank's reserves and reserves are derived
from deposits and through this
fractional Reserve System any one
deposit can create nine times its
original value in turn to basing the
existing money supply raising prices in
society and since all this money is
created out of debt and circulated
randomly through Commerce people become
detached from their original debt and a
disequilibrium exists where people are
forced to compete for labor in order to
pool enough money out of the money
supply to cover their costs of living
as dysfunctional and backwards as all of
this might seem there is still one thing
we have omitted from this equation
and it is this element of the structure
which reveals the truly fraudulent
nature of the system itself
the application of Interest
when the government borrows money from
the fed or when a person borrows money
from a bank it almost always has to be
paid back with a crude interest
in other words almost every single
dollar that exists must be eventually
returned to a bank with interest paid as
well
but if all money is borrowed from the
central bank and is expanded by
commercial Banks through loans
only what would be referred to as the
principal is being created in the money
supply
so then where is the money to cover all
of the interest that is charged
nowhere
it doesn't exist
the ramifications of this are staggering
for the amount of money owed back to the
banks will always exceed the amount of
money that is available in circulation
this is why inflation is a constant in
the economy for new money is always
needed to help cover the Perpetual
deficit built into the system caused by
the need to pay the interest what this
also means is that mathematically
defaults and bankruptcy are literally
built into the system and there will
always be poor pockets of society that
get the short end of the stick an
analogy would be a game of musical
chairs for once the Music Stops somebody
is left out to dry
and that's the point it invariably
transfers true wealth from the
individual to the banks for if you are
unable to pay for your mortgage they
will take your property this is
particularly enraging when you realize
that not only is such a default
inevitable due to the fractional Reserve
practice but also because of the fact
that the money that the Bank loaned to
you didn't even legally exist in the
first place
in 1969 there was a Minnesota Court case
involving a man named Jerome Daly who
was challenging the Foreclosure of his
home by the bank which provided the loan
to purchase it his argument was that the
mortgage contract required both parties
being he and the bank each put up a
legitimate form of property for the
exchange
in legal language this is called
consideration
[Music]
Mr Daly explained that the money was in
fact not the property of the bank for it
was created out of nothing as soon as
the loan agreement was signed remember
what modern money mechanics stated about
loans what did they do when they make
loans is to accept promissory notes in
exchange for credits reserves are
unchanged by the loan transactions but
deposit credits constitute new additions
to the total deposits of the banking
system in other words the money doesn't
come out of their existing assets the
bank is simply inventing it putting up
nothing of its own except for a
theoretical liability on paper
as the court case progressed the bank's
president Mr Morgan took the stand and
in the judge's personal memorandum he
recalled that the plaintiff thanks
president admitted that in combination
with the Federal Reserve Bank did create
the money and credit upon its books by
bookkeeping entry the money and credit
first came into existence when they
created it Mr Morgan admitted that no
United States law or statute existed
which gave him the right to do this a
lawful consideration must exist and be
tendered to support the known the jury
found that there was no lawful
consideration and I agree he also
poetically added only God can create
something of value out of nothing
and upon this Revelation the court
rejected the bank's claim for
foreclosure and daily kept his home
the implications of this court decision
are immense
for every time you borrow money from a
bank whether it is a mortgage loan or a
credit card charge
the money given to you is not only
counterfeit it is an illegitimate form
of consideration and hence voids the
contract to repay for the bank never had
the money as property to begin with
unfortunately such legal realizations
are suppressed and ignored and the game
of Perpetual wealth transfer and
Perpetual debt continues and this brings
us to the ultimate question
why
during the American Civil War President
Lincoln bypassed the high interest loans
offered by the European Banks and
decided to do what the founding fathers
advocated which was to create an
independent and inherently debt-free
currency it was called the Greenback
shortly after this measure was taken an
internal document circulated between
private British and American banking
interests stated slavery is but the
owning of Labor and carries with it the
care of laborers
while the European plan is that Capital
shall control labor by controlling wages
this can be done by controlling the
money it will not do to allow the
Greenback as we cannot control that
the fractional Reserve policy
perpetrated by the Federal Reserve which
has spread in practice to the great
majority of banks in the world is in
fact a system of modern slavery
think about it money is created out of
debt and what do people do when they are
in debt they submit to employment to pay
it off
but if money can only be created out of
loans how can Society ever be debt free
it can't and that's the point
and it is the fear of losing assets
coupled with the struggle to keep up
with the Perpetual debt and inflation
inherent in the system compounded by the
inescapable scarcity within the money
supply itself created by the interest
that can never be repaid
that keeps the wage slave in line
running on the hamster wheel with
millions of others in effect powering an
Empire that truly benefits only the
elite at the top of the pyramid
for at the end of the day who are you
really working for
the banks
money is created in a bank and
invariably ends up in a bank they are
the true Masters along with the
corporations and governments they
support
physical slavery requires people to be
housed and fed economic slavery requires
people to feed and house themselves
it is one of the most ingenious scams
for social manipulation ever created and
at its core it is an invisible war
against the population
debt is the weapon used to conquer and
enslave societies and interest is its
prime ammunition
and as the majority walks around
oblivious to this reality the banks in
collusion with governments and
corporations continue to perfect and
expand their tactics of economic Warfare
spawning new bases such as the World
Bank and international monetary fund
while also inventing a new type of
soldier
the birth of the economic Hitman
we economic Hitmen really have been the
ones responsible for creating this first
truly Global Empire and we work many
different ways
but perhaps the most common is that we
will identify a country that has
resources our corporations covet like
oil and then arrange a huge loan to that
country from the World Bank or one of
its sister organizations but the money
never actually goes to the country
instead it goes to our big corporations
to build infrastructure projects in that
Country power plants industrial parks
ports things that benefit a few rich
people in that country in addition to
our corporations but really don't have
the majority of the people at all
however those people the whole country
is left holding a huge debt such a big
debt they can't repaid and that's part
of the plan that they can't repay it and
so at some point we can only get men go
back to them and say listen you lost a
lot of money you can't pay your debt so
sell your oil real cheap to oil
companies allow us to build a military
base in your country or send troops in
support of ours to some place in the
world like Iraq or vote with us on the
next U.N vote to have their electric
utility company privatized and their
water and sewage system privatized and
sold to U.S corporations or other
multinational corporations so there was
a whole mushrooming thing and it's so
typical of the way the IMF and the World
Bank worked they put a country in debt
it's such a big data can't pay it and
then you offer to refinance that debt
and and pay even more interest
and you demand this quid pro quo which
you call a conditionality or good
governance
which means basically they've got to
sell off their resources and including
many of their social services their
utility companies their school systems
sometimes their their penal systems
their insurance systems to foreign
corporations so it's a it's a double
triple quadruple Whammy
the president for economic equipment
really began back in the early 50s when
democratically elected Musa deck who was
elected in Iran he was considered to be
the hope for democracy in the Middle
East and around the world he was a Time
magazine's man of the year but one of
the things that he'd run on and began to
implement was the idea that foreign oil
companies needed to pay the Iranian
people a lot more for the oil that they
were taking out of Iran the Iranian
people should benefit from their own oil
strange policy
we didn't like that of course but we
were afraid to do what we normally were
doing which was to send in the military
instead we sent in one CIA agent Kermit
Roosevelt Teddy Roosevelt's relative
and Kermit went in with a few million
dollars and was very very effective and
efficient and in a short amount of time
he managed to get Musa deck overthrown
and brought in the Shah of Iran to
replace him who always was favorable to
oil and it was extremely effective
moms overflow Terran army officers shout
that masadeka surrendered and his regime
as virtual dictator of Iran is ended
pictures of the shaw paraded through the
streets as sediment reverses
the show is welcomed home
so back here in the United States in
Washington people looked around and said
wow that was easy and cheap so this
established a whole new way of
manipulating countries of creating
Empire the only problem with Roosevelt
was that he was a card-carrying CIA
agent and had been caught the
ramifications could have been pretty
serious so very quickly at that point
the decision was made to use private
Consultants to to channel the money
through the World Bank or the IMF or one
of the other such agencies to bring in
people like me who worked for private
companies so that if we got caught there
would be no governmental ramifications
when Urban became president of Guatemala
the country was very much under the
thumbs of United Fruit Company the the
big International corporations and our
events ran on this ticket that says you
know we want to get the land back to the
people and once he took power he was he
was implementing policies that would
that would do exactly that give the land
rights back to the people United Fruit
didn't like that very much and so they
hired a public relations firm launched a
huge campaign in the United States to
convince the United States people the
citizens of the United States and the
Press of the United States and the
Congress of the United States that our
Benz was a Soviet puppet and that if we
allowed him to stay in power the Soviets
would have a foothold in this in this
Hemisphere and that at that point in
time was a huge fear on everybody's mind
the Red Terror or the Communist Terror
and so to make a long story short out of
this public relations campaign came a
commitment on the part of the CIA in the
military to take this man out and in
fact we did we send planes we sent in we
sent in soldiers we said in jackals we
send everything in to take him out and
did take him out and as soon as he was
removed from office the new guy that
took over after him basically reinstated
everything to the big International
corporations including United Fruit
Ecuador for many many years had been
ruled by pro-us dictators often
relatively brutal then it was decided
that they were going to have a truly
democratic election how many rolled oats
ran for office and his main goal is that
as president would be to make sure that
Ecuador's resources were used to help
the people and he won overwhelming by
more votes than anybody that ever won
anything in Ecuador and he began to
implement these policies to make sure
that the profits from oil went to help
the people well we didn't like that in
the United States I was sent down as one
of several economic Hitmen to change
roles to corrupt him to bring him around
to let him know you know okay you know
you can get very rich you and your
family if you if you play our game but
if you just if you continue to try to
keep these policies you've promised
um you you're going to go you wouldn't
listen
he was assassinated
as soon as the plane crashed the whole
area was cordoned off the only people
allowed in the U.S military from from a
nearby base and some of the Ecuadorian
military when an investigation was
launched two of the key Witnesses died
in car accidents before they had a
chance to testify a lot of very very
strange things that weren't on around
the the assassination of high mineral
dose I like most
people who've really looked at this case
had absolutely no doubt that it was an
assassination and of course in my
position as an economic Hitman I was
always expecting something to happen to
Jaime whether it be a coup or
assassination I wasn't sure but that you
would be taken down because he was not
being corrupted he would not allow
himself to be corrupted the way we
wanted to corrupt him
foreign
president of Panama was you know one of
my favorite people I really really liked
him he was very charismatic he was a guy
who really wanted to help his country
and when I tried to bribe him or corrupt
him he said look John he called me
Juanito he said look Juanito
um I don't need the money what I really
need is for my country
treated fairly
I need for the United States to repay
the debts that you owe my people for all
the destruction you've done here I need
to be in a position where I can help
other Latin American countries win their
Independents and and be free of this of
this terrible presence from the north
that you people are exploiting us so
badly I need to have the Panama Canal
back in the hands of the Panamanian
people that's what I want and so leave
me alone don't you know don't try don't
try to bribe me it was 1981 and in May
Jaime roldos was assassinated and Omar
was very aware of this Tori has got his
family together and he said I'm probably
next
but it's okay because I've done what I
came here to do I renegotiated the canal
the canal will now be in our hands he
just finished negotiating the treaty
with Jimmy Carter
[Music]
in June of that same year just a couple
of months later
he also went out in an airplane crash
which there's no question was executed
by CIA sponsored jackals tremendous
amount of evidence that one of the one
of treehouse's security guards handed
him at the last moment as he was getting
on the plane a tape recorder a small
tape recorder that contained a bomb
[Music]
it is interesting to me how this system
has continued pretty much the same way
for years and years and years except the
economic Hitmen have got better and
better and better then we come up with
very recently what happened in Venezuela
in 1998 Hugo Chavez gets elected
president following a long line of
presidents who had been very corrupt and
basically destroyed the economy of the
country and Chavez was elected to Mr all
that Chavez stood up to the United
States
and he's done it primarily demanding
that Venezuelan oil
be used to help the Venezuelan people
well we didn't like that in the United
States so in 2002 the coolest age which
is no question in my mind of most other
people's minds the CIA was behind that
coup
come on
the way that that coup was fomented was
very reflective of what Kermit Roosevelt
had done in Iran of paying people to go
out into the streets to Riot to protest
to say this Chavez is very unpopular
you know if you can get a few thousand
people who do that in television
can make it look like it's a whole
country and things start to mushroom
except in the case of Chavez he was
smart enough and the people were so
strongly behind him that they overcame
it
which was a phenomenal moment in the
history of Latin America
Iraq actually is a perfect example of
the way the whole system works so we
economic Hitmen are the first line of
defense we go in we try to corrupt
governments and get them to accept these
huge loans which we then use as leverage
to basically own them
if we fail as I failed in in Panama with
Omar Tarios and Ecuador with Jaime World
dose men who refuse to be corrupted then
the second line of defense is we send in
the jackals and the jackals either
overthrow governments or they
assassinate and once that happens when a
new government comes in and boy it's
going to toe the line because the new
president knows what will happen if he
doesn't
in the case of Iraq both of those things
failed economic equipment were not able
to get through to Saddam Hussein we
tried very hard we tried to get him to
accept a deal very similar to what the
house of Saud had accepted in Saudi
Arabia but he wouldn't accept it and so
the jackals went in to take him out they
couldn't do it his security was very
good
um after all he had one time worked for
the CRA he'd been hired to assassinate a
former president of of Iraq and failed
but he knew the system
so in 91 we send in the troops and we
take out the Iraqi military so we assume
at that point that Saddam Hussein is
going to come around we could have taken
him out of course at that time but we
didn't want to he's a kind of strong man
we like he controls his people we
thought he could control the Kurds and
keep the Iranians in their border and
keep pumping oil for us and then once we
took out his military now he's going to
come around
so the economic Hitmen go back in in the
90s without success if they'd had
success he'd still be running the
country we'd be selling them all the
fighter jets he wants and everything
else he wants but they couldn't they
they didn't have success the jackals
couldn't take him out again so we sent
the military in once again and this time
we did the complete job and took him out
and in the process created for ourselves
some very very lucrative construction
deals I had to reconstruct a country
that we'd essentially destroyed which is
a pretty good deal if you own
construction companies big ones
so you know Iraq shows the three stages
the economic Hitmen failed there the
jackals failed there and as a final
measure the military goes in
and in that way we've really created an
Empire but we've done it very very
subtly it's clandestine all the empires
of the past were built on the military
and everybody knew they were building
them so the britisher they were building
it the French the Germans the Romans the
Greeks
and they were proud of it and they
always had some excuse like spreading
civilization spreading some religion
something like that but they knew they
were doing it we don't the majority of
the people in the United States have no
idea that we're living off the benefits
of the clandestine Empire that today
there's more slavery in the world than
ever before
[Music]
and then you have to ask yourself well
if this if it's an Empire then who's the
emperor
obviously in our presidents of the
United States are not Emperors and
Emperor is someone who's not elected
doesn't serve a limited term and doesn't
report to anyone essentially so you
can't classify a president's that way
but we do have what I consider to be the
equivalent of the emperor and it's what
I call the corporatocracy
corporatocracy is this group of
individuals who run our biggest
corporations and they really act as the
Emperor of this Empire
they control our media either through
direct ownership or advertising they
control most of our politicians because
they finance their campaigns either
through their corporations or through
personal contributions that come out of
the corporations
they're not elected They don't serve a
limited term they don't report to
anybody and at the very top of the Court
protocracy you really can't tell whether
a person's working for a private
Corporation or the government because
they're always moving back and forth so
you know you've got a guy who one moment
is the president of of a big
construction company like Halliburton in
the next moment he's Vice President of
the United States or the president who
was in the oil business and and this is
true whether you've got Democrats or
Republicans in the office you have to
moving back and forth through the
revolving door and in a way our
government is is invisible a lot of the
time and its policies are carried out by
our corporations on one level or another
and then again the policies of the
government are basically
forged by the corporatocracy and then
presented to the government they become
government policy so it's an incredibly
cozy relationship this isn't a
conspiracy theory type of thing these
people don't have to get together and
and plot to do things they all basically
work under one primary assumption and
that is that they must maximize profits
regardless of the social and
environmental costs
this process of manipulation by the
corporatocracy through the use of debt
bribery and political overthrow is
called globalization
just as the Federal Reserve keeps the
American public in a position of
indentured servitude through Perpetual
debt inflation and interest the World
Bank and IMF serve this role on a global
scale
the basic scam is simple
put a country in debt either by its own
indiscretion or through corrupting the
leader of that country
then impose conditionalities or
structural adjustment policies often
consisting of the following
currency devaluation when the value of a
currency drops so does everything valued
in it this makes indigenous resources
available to Predator countries at a
fraction of their worth
large funding cuts for social programs
these usually include education and
Health Care compromising the well-being
and integrity of the society leaving the
public vulnerable to exploitation
privatization of state-owned Enterprises
this means that socially important
systems can be purchased and regulated
by Foreign corporations for profit for
example in 1999 the World Bank insisted
that the Bolivian government sell the
public water system of its third largest
city to a subsidy of the U.S corporation
Bechtel as soon as this occurred water
bills for the already impoverished local
residents skyrocketed
it wasn't until after a full-blown
Revolt by the people that the Bechtel
contract was nullified
then there's trade liberalization or the
opening up of the economy through
removing any restrictions on foreign
trade this allows for a number of
abusive economic manifestations such as
transnational corporations bringing in
their own mass-produced products
undercutting the indigenous production
and ruining local economies
an example is Jamaica
which after accepting loans and
conditionalities from the World Bank
lost its largest cash crop markets due
to competition with Western Imports
today countless farmers are out of work
for they are unable to compete with the
large corporations
another variation is the creation of
numerous seemingly unnoticed unregulated
inhumane Sweatshop factories which take
advantage of the imposed economic
hardship
additionally due to production
deregulation environmental destruction
is Perpetual as a country's resources
are often exploited by the indifferent
corporations while outputting large
amounts of deliberate pollution
the largest environmental lawsuit in the
history of the world today is being
brought on behalf of thirty thousand
Ecuadorian Amazonian people against
Texaco which is now owned by Chevron so
today it's against Chevron but for
activities conducted by Texaco
they estimated to be more than 18 times
with Exxon Valdez dumped into the coast
of Alaska in the case of Ecuador it
wasn't an accident the oil companies did
it intentionally they knew they were
doing it to save money out there rather
than other than arranging for a proper
disposal
furthermore a cursory glance at the
performance record of the World Bank
reveals that the institution which
publicly claims to help poor countries
develop and alleviate poverty has done
nothing but increase poverty and the
wealth Gap while corporate profits soar
in 1960 the income gap between the fifth
of the world's people in the richest
countries versus the fifth in the
poorest countries was 30 to 1. by 1998
it was 74 to 1.
while Global GNP Rose 40 between 1970
and 1985 those in poverty actually
increased by 17 while from 1985 to 2000
those living on less than one dollar a
day increased by 18 percent
even the joint economic Committee of the
U.S Congress admitted that there is a
mere 40 percent success rate of all
World Bank projects in the late 1960s
the World Bank intervened in Ecuador
with large loans during the next 30
Years poverty grew from 50 to 70 percent
under or unemployment Grew From 15 to 70
percent
public debt increased from 240 million
to 16 billion while the share of
resources allocated to the poor went
from 20 percent to six percent
in fact by the year two thousand fifty
percent of Ecuador's national budget had
to be allocated for paying its debts
it is important to understand the world
bank is in fact a U.S Bank supporting
U.S interests for the United States
holds veto power over decisions as it is
the largest provider of capital
and where did it get this money you
guessed it it made it out of thin air
through the fractional Reserve banking
system
of the world's top 100 economies as
based on annual GDP 51 are corporations
and 47 of that 51 are U.S based
Walmart General Motors and Exxon are
more economically powerful than Saudi
Arabia Poland Norway South Africa
Finland Indonesia and many others
and as protective trade barriers are
broken down currencies tossed together
and manipulated in floating markets and
state economies overturned in favor of
open competition and global capitalism
the Empire expands
you get up on your little 21-inch screen
and howl about America and democracy
there is no America
there is no democracy
there is only IBN and Itt and a t
and Dupont Dao Union Carbide
and Exxon
those are the nations of the world today
what do you think the Russians talk
about in their council's estate Karl
Marx
they get out their linear programming
charts statistical decision theories
Minimax Solutions and compute the price
cost probabilities of their transactions
and investments just like we do
we no longer live in a world of Nations
and ideologies Mr Beale
the world is a
College of Corporations
inexorably determined by the
immutable bylaws of business
the world
is a business Mr Beale
the world is being taken over by a
handful of business Powers who dominate
the natural resources we need to Live
While controlling the money we need to
obtain these resources
the end result will be World Monopoly
based not on human life but financial
and corporate power
and as the inequality grows naturally
more and more people are becoming
desperate
so the establishment was forced to come
up with a new way to deal with anyone
who challenges the system
so they gave birth to the terrorist
the term terrorist is an empty
distinction
designed for any person or group who
chooses to challenge The Establishment
this isn't to be confused with the
fictional Al-Qaeda which was actually
the name of a computer database for the
U.S supported mujahideen in the 1980s
foreign
[Music]
the Department of Defense received
161.8 billion dollars for the so-called
global war on terrorism
according to the National
counter-terrorism Center in 2004 roughly
2 000 people were killed internationally
due to supposed terrorist Acts of that
number 70 were American
using this number as a general average
which is extremely generous
it is interesting to note that twice as
many people die from peanut allergies a
year than from terrorist Acts
concurrently the leading cause of death
in America is coronary heart disease
killing roughly 450 000 each year
and in 2007 the government's allocation
of funds for research on this issue was
about three billion dollars
this means that the U.S government in
2007 spent 54 times the amount for
preventing terrorism than it spent for
preventing a disease which kills
6600 times more people annually than
terrorism does
yet as the name terrorism in Al Qaeda
are arbitrarily stamped on every news
report relating to any action taken
against U.S interests the myth grows
wider in mid-2008 the U.S attorney
general actually proposed that the U.S
Congress officially declare war against
the fantasy
not to mention as of July 2008 there are
now over 1 million people currently on
the U.S terrorist watch list
these so-called counter-terrorism
measures of course have nothing to do
with social protection and everything to
do with preserving The Establishment
amongst the growing anti-American
sentiment both domestically and
internationally
which is legitimately founded on the
greed-based corporate Empire expansion
that is exploiting the world
the true terrorists of our world do not
meet at the Docks at midnight or scream
Allah Akbar before some violent action
the true terrorists of our world where a
five thousand dollar suits and work in
the highest positions of Finance
government and business
so what do we do
how do we stop a system of greed and
Corruption that has so much power and
momentum how do we stop this aberrant
group Behavior which feels no compassion
for say the millions slaughtered in Iraq
and Afghanistan
so the court protocracy can control
energy resources and opium production
for Wall Street profit
all right
how do we stop a system of greed and
Corruption that condemns poor
populations to Sweatshop slavery for the
benefit of Madison Avenue
or that Engineers false flag terror
attacks for the sake of manipulation
or that generates built-in modes of
social operation which are inherently
exploitative
or that systematically reduces civil
liberties and violates human rights in
order to protect itself from its own
shortcomings
how do we deal with the numerous covert
institutions such as the Council on
Foreign Relations the trilateral
commission and the Bilderberg Group and
other undemocratically elected groups
which behind closed doors collude to
control the political Financial social
and environmental elements of Our Lives
in order to find the answer
we must first find the true underlying
cause
for the fact is the selfish corrupt
power and profit-based groups are not
the true source of the problem
they are symptoms
my name is Jacques Fresco
I'm an industrial designer and a social
engineer
I'm very much interested in society
in developing A system that might be
sustainable for all people
first of all the word corruption is a
monetary invention that aberrant
Behavior Behavior that's disruptive to
the well-being of people while you're
dealing with human behavior and human
behavior appears to be environmentally
determined meaning if you were raised by
the seminal Indians as a baby never saw
anything else you'd hold that value
system and this goes for Nations it goes
for individuals for families they try to
indoctrinate their children to their
particular faith and their country and
make them feel like they're part of that
and they build a society which they call
established
they establish a workable point of view
and tend to perpetuate that whereas all
societies are really emergent not
established
and so they fight new ideas that would
interfere with the establishment
governments try to perpetuate that which
keeps them in power
people are not elected to political
office to change things that put there
to keep things the way they are
so you see the basis of corruption is in
our society let me make it clear all
nations then are basically corrupt
because they tend to uphold existing
institutions I don't mean to uphold or
downgrade All Nations but communism
socialism fascism the free enterprise
system and all other subcultures are the
same they are all basically corrupt
the most fundamental characteristic of
our social institutions is the necessity
for self-preservation whether dealing
with a corporation a religion or a
government
the foremost interest is to preserve the
institution itself
for instance the last thing an oil
company would ever want is the
utilization of energy that was outside
of its control for what makes that
company less relevant to society
likewise the Cold War and the collapse
of the Soviet Union was in reality a way
to preserve and perpetuate the
established economic and Global hegemony
of the United States
foreign
ly religions conditioned people to feel
guilty for natural inclinations each
claiming to offer the only path to
forgiveness and salvation
at the heart of this institutional
self-preservation lies the monetary
system for it is money that provides the
means for power and survival
therefore just as a poor person might be
forced to steal in order to survive it
is a natural inclination to do whatever
is needed to continue an institution's
profitability
this makes it inherently difficult for
profit-based institutions to change for
it puts in Jeopardy not only the
survival of large groups of people but
also the coveted materialistic
Lifestyles associated with affluence and
Power
therefore the paralyzing necessity to
preserve an institution regardless of
its social relevance is largely rooted
in the need for money or profit
thank you
what's in it for me is why people think
and so if a man makes money selling a
certain product naturally he's going to
fight the existence of another product
that may threaten his Institution
therefore people cannot be fair
and people do not trust each other a guy
will come over to you and say I got just
the house you're looking for he's a
Salesman one of the doctor says I think
your kidney has to come out I don't know
if he's trying to pay off a yacht
whether my kidney has to come out it's
hard in a monetary system to trust
people
if you came into my store and I said
this lamp that I've got is pretty good
but the lamp is next door is much better
I wouldn't be in business very long it
wouldn't work if I were ethical it
wouldn't work
So when you say industry cares for
people that's not true they can't afford
to be ethical
so your system is not designed to serve
the well-being of people if you still
don't understand that there would be no
Outsourcing of jobs if they cared about
people industry does not care they only
hire people because it hasn't been
automated yet
so I don't talk about decency and ethics
we cannot afford it and remain in
business
it is important to point out that
regardless of the social system whether
fascist socialist capitalist or
communist the underlying mechanism is
still money labor and competition
communist China is no less capitalistic
than the United States the only
difference is the degree by which the
state intervenes in Enterprise
the reality is that monetarism so to
speak is the true mechanism that guides
the interests of all the countries on
the planet
the most aggressive and hence dominant
variation of this monetarism is the free
enterprise system
the fundamental perspective as put forth
by early free market economists like
Adam Smith is that self-interest in
competition leads to social Prosperity
as the act of competition creates
incentive which motivates people to
persevere
however what isn't talked about is how a
competition-based economy invariably
leads to strategic corruption power and
wealth consolidation social
stratification technological paralysis
labor abuse and ultimately a covert form
of government dictatorship by the rich
Elite
the word corruption is often defined as
moral perversion if a company dumps
toxic waste into the ocean to save money
most people recognize this as corrupt
Behavior on a more subtle level
when Walmart moves into a small town and
forces small businesses to shut down for
they are unable to compete a gray area
emerges for what exactly is Walmart
doing wrong
why should they care about Mom and Pop
organizations they destroy
yet even more subtly when a person gets
fired from their job because a new
machine has been created which can do
the work for less money people tend to
just accept that as the way it is not
seeing the inherent corrupt inhumanity
of such an action
because the fact is whether it is
dumping toxic waste having a monopoly
Enterprise or downsizing the workforce
the motive is the same
profit
they are all different degrees of the
same self-preserving mechanism which
always puts the well-being of people
second to monetary gain
therefore corruption is not some
byproduct of monetarism it is the very
Foundation
and while most people acknowledge this
tendency on one level or another the
majority remains naive as to the broad
ramifications of having such a selfish
mechanism as The Guiding mentality in
society internal documents show that
after this company positively absolutely
knew that they had a medication that was
infected with the AIDS virus they took
the product off the market in the U.S
and then they dumped it in France Europe
Asia and Latin America the U.S
government allowed it to happen the FDA
allowed this to happen and now the
government is completely looking the
other way thousands of innocent
hemophiliacs have died from the AIDS
virus this company knew absolutely that
it was infected with AIDS they dumped it
because they wanted to turn This
Disaster into a profit
so you see you have built-in corruption
we're all chiseling off each other and
you can't expect decency and that sort
of thing
and feeling that they don't know who to
elect they think in terms of a democracy
which is not possible in a monetary
based economy if you have more money to
advertise your position the position you
desire in government that is in a
democracy that serves those in positions
of differential Advantage so it's always
a dictatorship of the elitist the
financially wealthy
foreign
[Music]
it is an interesting observation to note
how seemingly unknown personalities
magically appear on the scene as
presidential candidates
then before you know it somehow you are
left to choose from a small group of
extremely wealthy people who
suspiciously have the same Broad Social
View
obviously it's a joke
the people placed on the ballot are done
so because they have been pre-decided to
be acceptable by the established
Financial Powers who actually run the
show
yet many who understand this illusion of
democracy often think if only we could
just get our honest ethical politicians
in power then we would be okay
well while this idea of course seems
reasonable in our established oriented
worldview it is unfortunately another
fallacy
for when it really comes down to what is
actually important the institution of
politics and thus politicians themselves
have absolutely no true relevance as to
what makes our world and Society
function
it's not politicians that can solve
problems they have no technical
capabilities they don't know how to
solve problems even if they were sincere
they don't know how to solve problems
it's a technicians that produce the
desalinization plans it's the
technicians that give you electricity
that give you motor vehicles that heat
your house and cool it the summer time
it's technology that solves problems not
politics politics cannot solve problem
because they're not trained to do so
very few people today stop and consider
what it is that actually improves their
lives
is it money obviously not one cannot eat
money or stuff money into their car to
get it to run
is it politics
all politicians can do is create laws
establish budgets and declare war
is it religion of course not religion
creates nothing except intangible
emotional Solace for those who require
it
the true gift that we as human beings
have which has been solely responsible
for everything that has improved Our
Lives is technology
what is technology technology is a
pencil which allows one to solidify
ideas on paper for communication
technology is an automobile which allows
one to travel faster than feet would
allow
technology is a pair of eyeglasses which
enables sight for those who need it
[Music]
applied technology itself is merely an
extension of human attributes which
reduces human effort freeing humans from
a particular chore or problem
imagine what your life would be like
today without a telephone or an oven or
a computer or an airplane everything in
your home which you take for granted
from a doorbell to a table to a
dishwasher is technology generated from
the creative scientific Ingenuity of
human technicians
not money politics or religion these are
false institutions
and writing your congressman is
fantastic they tend you to write your
Congressman if you want something done
the men in Washington should be at the
Forefront of Technology the Forefront of
human studies the Forefront of crime all
the factors that shape human behavior
you don't have to write your Congressman
what kind of people are they that are
that are appointed to do that job
the future will have great difficulty
and the question that's raised by
politicians is how much will a project
cost
the question is not how much will it
cost do we have the resources
and we have the resources today to house
everyone build hospitals all over the
world build schools all over the world
the finest equipment and labs for
teaching and doing medical research
so you see we have all that but we're in
the monetary system and in the monetary
system there's profit
and what is the fundamental mechanism
that drives the profit system besides
self-interest what is it exactly that
maintains that Competitive Edge at its
core is it high efficiency and
sustainability no that isn't part of
their design nothing produced in our
profit-based society is even remotely
sustainable or efficient if it was there
wouldn't be a multi-million dollar a
year service industry for automobiles
nor would the average lifespan for most
Electronics be less than three months
before they're obsolete
is it abundance
absolutely not abundance as based on the
laws of supply and demand is actually a
negative thing if a diamond company
finds 10 times the usual amount of
diamonds during their mining it means
the supply of diamonds has increased
which means the cost and profit per
Diamond drops
the fact is efficiency sustainability
and abundance are enemies of profit to
put it into a word it is the mechanism
of scarcity that increases profits
what is scarcity based on keeping
products valuable slowing up production
on oil raises the price
maintaining scarcity of diamonds keeps
the price high they burn diamonds at the
Kimberly diamond mines they made a
carbon that keeps the price up so then
what does it mean for society when
scarcity either produced naturally or
through manipulation is a beneficial
condition for industry
[Music]
it means that sustainability and
abundance will never ever occur in a
profit system for it simply goes against
the very nature of the structure
therefore it is impossible to have a
world without war or poverty
it is impossible to continually Advance
technology to its most efficient and
productive States
and most dramatically
it is impossible to expect human beings
to behave in truly ethical or decent
ways
foreign
[Music]
because they can't account for the
behavior
they sit back and they evaluate with
their lack of knowledge you know and
they say things like
humans have built a certain way greed is
a natural thing and so they've worked
for years on it and it's no more natural
than wearing clothing
what we want to do is to eliminate
the causes of the problems eliminate the
processes that that produce greed and
bigotry and Prejudice and people taking
advantage of one another and elitism
eliminating the need for prisons and
Welfare we have always had these
problems because we have always lived
within scarcity and barter and monetary
systems that produce scarcity if you
eradicate the conditions that generate
what you call socially offensive
Behavior it does not exist the guy said
well listen that inborn no it's not
there is no human nature there's human
behavior and that's always been changed
throughout history you're not born with
bigotry and greed and Corruption and
hatred you you pick that up within the
society
War poverty corruption hunger misery
human suffering will not change in the
monetary system that is there'll be very
little significant change it's going to
take the redesign of our culture our
values and it has to be related to the
carrying capacity of the earth not some
human opinion or some politicians
Notions of the way the world ought to be
or some religious Notions of the conduct
of human affairs
and that's what the Venus Project is
about
the society that we're about to talk
about is a society that is free of all
the old superstitions incarceration
prisons police cruelty and law all laws
will disappear and the professions will
disappear that are no longer valid such
as stock Brokers Bankers advertising
gone forever because it's no longer
relevant
when we understand that it is technology
devised by human Ingenuity which frees
humanity and increases our quality of
life we then realize that the most
important Focus we can have is on the
intelligent management of the Earth's
resources for it is from these natural
resources we gain the materials to
continue our path of prosperity
understanding this we then see that
money fundamentally exists as a barrier
to these resources for virtually
everything has a financial cost
and why do we need money to obtain these
resources because of real or assumed
scarcity
we don't usually pay for air and tap
water because it is in such high
abundance selling it would be pointless
so then logically speaking if resources
and Technologies applicable to creating
everything in our societies such as
houses cities and transportation
we're in high enough abundance there
would be no reason to sell anything
likewise if Automation and Machinery was
so technologically advanced as to
relieve human beings of Labor there
would be no reason to have a job
and with these social aspects taken care
of there would be no reason to have
money at all
so the ultimate question remains
do we on earth have enough resources and
technological understanding to create a
society of such abundance that
everything we have now could be
available without a price tag and
without the need for submission through
employment
yes we do
we have the resources and Technology to
enable this at a minimum along with the
ability to raise the standard of living
so high that people in the future will
look back at our Civilization now and
gawk at how primitive and immature our
society was
what the Venus Project proposes is an
entirely different system that's updated
to present-day knowledge we've never
given scientists the problem of how do
you design a society which would
eliminate boring and monotonous jobs
that would eliminate accidents in
transportation that would enable people
to have a high standard of living that
would eliminate poisons in our food that
would give us other sources of energy
that are clean and efficient we can do
that out there
the major difference between a
resource-based economy and a monetary
system is that a resource-based economy
is really concerned with people and
their well-being we're a monetary system
has become so distorted that the
concerns of the people are really
secondary if they're there at all the
products that are turned out are for how
much money you can get if there is a
problem in society and you can't earn
money from solving that problem then it
won't be done
the resource-based economy is really not
close to anything that's been tried and
with all our technology today we can
create abundance it could be used to
improve everyone's lifestyle abundance
all over the world if we use our
technology wisely and maintain the
environment it's a very different system
and it's very hard to talk about because
the public is not that well enough
informed as to the state of Technology
myself
at present we don't have to burn fossil
fuels we don't have to use anything that
would contaminate the environment there
are many sources of energy available
Alternative Energy Solutions pushed by
The Establishment such as hydrogen
biomass and even nuclear are highly
insufficient dangerous and exist only to
perpetuate The Profit structure that
industry has created
when we look beyond the propaganda and
self-serving Solutions put forth by the
energy companies we find a seemingly
endless stream of clean abundant and
renewable energy for generating power
solar and wind energy are well known to
the public but the true potential of
these mediums remains unexpressed
solar energy derived from the sun has
such abundance that one hour of light at
High Noon contains more energy than what
the entire world consumes in a year if
we could Capture One Hundredth of a
percent of this energy the world would
never have to use oil gas or anything
else
the question then is not availability
but the technology to harness it and
there are many Advanced mediums today
which could accomplish just that if they
were not hindered by the need to compete
for market share with the established
Energy power structures
then there's wind energy wind energy has
long been denounced as weak and due to
being location driven impractical this
is simply not true the U.S department of
energy admitted in 2007 that if wind was
fully harvested in just three of
America's 50 states it could power the
entire nation
and then there are the rather unknown
mediums of title and wave power
tidal power is derived from title shifts
in the ocean installing turbines which
capture this movement generates energy
in the United Kingdom 42 sites are
currently noted as available forecasting
that 34 percent of all the UK's energy
could come from tidal power alone
wave power which extracts energy from
the surface motions of the ocean is
estimated to have a global potential of
up to 80 000 terawatt hours a year
this means 50 of the entire planet's
energy usage could be produced from this
medium alone
now it is important to point out that
Title Wave solar and wind power requires
virtually no preliminary energy to
harness unlike coal oil gas biomass
hydrogen and all the others in
combination these four mediums alone if
efficiently harnessed through technology
could power the world forever
that being said there happens to be
another form of clean renewable energy
which trumps them all
geothermal power
geothermal energy utilizes what is
called heat mining which through a
simple process using water is able to
generate massive amounts of clean energy
in 2006 an MIT report on geothermal
energy found that 13 000 Zeta joules of
Power are currently available in the
Earth with the possibility of two
thousand Zeta joules being easily
tappable with improved technology
the total energy consumption of all the
countries on the planet is about half of
a Zeta Julie year this means about 4 000
years of planetary power could be
harnessed in this medium alone
and when we understand that the Earth's
heat generation is constantly renewed
this energy is really Limitless and
could be used forever
these energy sources are only a few of
the clean renewable mediums available
and as time goes on we will find more
the grand realization is that we have
total energy abundance without the need
for pollution traditional conservation
or in fact a a price tag
and what about transportation
the prevailing means of transportation
in our societies is by automobile and
aircraft both of which predominantly
need fossil fuels to run
in the case of the automobile The
Battery Technology needed to power an
electric car that can go over 100 miles
an hour for over 200 miles on one charge
exists and has existed for many years
however due to battery patents
controlled by the oil industry which
limits their availability to maintain
market share coupled with political
pressure from the energy industry the
accessibility and affordability of this
technology is limited there is
absolutely no reason other than pure
corrupt profit interest that every
single vehicle in the world cannot be
electric and utterly clean with zero
need for gasoline
as far as airplanes it is time we
realize that this means of travel is
inefficient cumbersome slow and causes
far too much pollution
this is a maglev train it uses magnets
for propulsion it is fully suspended by
a magnetic field and requires less than
two percent of the energy used for plane
travel
the train has no wheels so nothing can
wear out
the current maximum speed of versions of
this technology as used in Japan is 361
miles per hour
however this version of the technology
is very dated
an organization called et3 which has
connections with the Venus Project has
established a tube-based maglev that can
travel up to 4 000 miles per hour in a
motionless frictionless tube which can
go over land or underwater
imagine going from LA to New York for an
extended lunch break or from Washington
DC to Beijing China in two hours
this is the future of continental and
InterContinental travel fast clean with
only a fraction of the energy usage we
use today for the same means
in fact between maglev technology
advanced battery storage and geothermal
energy there would be no reason to ever
burn fossil fuels again
and we can do this now if we were not
held back by the paralyzing profit
structure
now America is inclined towards fascism
it has a propensity by its dominant
philosophy and religion to uphold the
fastest point of view American Ministry
has essentially a fascist institution if
you don't understand that the minute you
punch that time clock you walk into a
dictatorship we're given Notions about
the respectability of work and I really
look at it as being paid slavery
they brought up to believe that you
shall earn your living by the sweat of
your brow that holds people back
freeing people
from drudgery repetitive jobs which make
them ignorant you rob them
you know our society that is a
resource-based economy machines free
people you see we can't imagine that as
we've never known that kind of world
thank you
if we look back at history we see a very
clear pattern of machine automation
slowly replacing human labor
from The Disappearance of the elevator
man to the near full automation of an
automobile production plant the fact is
as technology grows the need for humans
in the workforce will continually be
diminished
this creates a serious Clash which
proves the falseness of the
monetary-based labor system
for human employment is in direct
competition with technological
development
therefore given the fundamental priority
of profit by industry people through
time will be continually laid off and
replaced by Machine when industry takes
on the machine instead of shortening the
workday they downsize you lose your job
so you have a right to fear machines
in a high technology resource-based
economy it is conservative to say that
about 90 percent of all current
occupations could be phased out by
machines freeing humans to live their
life without servitude for this is the
point of Technology itself
and Through Time with nanotechnology and
other highly Advanced forms of science
it is not far-fetched to see how even
complex medical procedures could be
performed by machines as well
and based on the pattern with much
higher success rates than humans get
today
the path is clear but our monetary based
structure which requires labor for
income blocks this progress for humans
need jobs in order to survive
the bottom line is that this system must
go or we will never be free and
Technology will be constantly paralyzed
we have machines that clean out sewers
it frees a human being from doing that
so look at machines as extensions of
human performance
furthermore many occupations today will
have simply no basis to exist in a
resource-based economy such as anything
associated with the management of money
advertising along with the legal system
itself
for without money a great majority of
the crimes that are committed today
would never occur virtually all forms of
crime are a consequence of the monetary
system either directly or by neuroses
inflicted through financial deprivation
therefore laws themselves could
eventually become extinct
instead of putting up a sign drive
carefully Slippery When Wet put abrasive
in the highway so it's not slippery but
wet and if a person gets into contact
drunk and a car oscillates a great deal
there's a little pendulum that swings up
and back and that'll pull the car over
the side not a law
solution put sonar and radar and
Automobiles so they can't hit one
another man-made laws are attempts to
deal with occurring problems and not
knowing how to solve them they make a
law in the United States the most
privatized capitalist country on the
planet it should come as no surprise
that it also has the largest prison
population in the world
growing every year
statistically most of these people are
uneducated and come from poor deprived
societies
and contrary to propaganda it is this
environmental conditioning which lures
them into criminal and violent Behavior
however society looks the other way in
regard to this point
the legal and prison systems are just
more examples of how our society avoids
examining the root causes of behavior
billions are spent each year on prisons
and police while only a fraction is
spent on programs for poverty which is
one of the most fundamental variables
responsible for Crime to begin with and
as long as we have an economic system
which prefers and in fact creates
scarcity and deprivation crime will
never go away
if people have access to the necessities
of life without servitude debt barter
trade
they behave very differently you want
all these things available without a
price tag now then
you've got to have a price tag well what
will motivate people uh man gets
everything he wants he just lay around
in the sun this is the myths they
perpetuate people in our culture are
trained to believe that the monetary
system produces incentive if they have
access to things why should they want to
do anything they will lose their
incentive that's what you're taught to
support the monetary system when you
take money out of the scenario
there would be different and incentives
very different incentives when people
have access to the necessities of life
their incentives change what about the
moon and the stars
new incentives arise if you make a
painting that you enjoy you will enjoy
giving it to other people not selling it
I think most of the education that I've
seen today is essentially producing a
person for a job it's very specialized
they're not generalists people don't
know a lot about a lot of different
subjects I I don't think you could get
people to go to war if if they knew a
lot about a lot of things I think
education is mostly Road
and they're not taught how to solve
problems they're not given the tools
emotionally or within their own field of
how to do critical thinking a
resource-based economy the education
would be very different our society's
major concern as mental development and
to motivate each person to their Highest
Potential because our philosophy is the
smarter people are the Richer the world
because everybody becomes a contributor
the smarter your kids are the better my
life will be because they'll be
contributing more constructively to the
to the environment and to my life
because everything that we devise within
a resource-based economy would be
applied to society there would be
nothing to hold it back
patriotism
weapons armies navies all as a sign that
we're not civilized yet kids will ask
their parents didn't you see the
necessity of machines dad couldn't you
see that war was inevitable when you
produce scarcity
isn't it obvious of course the kid will
understand that you were pinheads raised
merely to serve the established
institutions was such an abominable sick
society that we won't make the history
book they just say that large Nations
took lands with smaller Nations use
force and violence you'll get history
talked about as corrupt Behavior All the
Way along until the beginning of the
Civilized world that's when all the
nations work together
World unification working toward common
good for all human beings and without
anyone being subservient to anyone else
without social stratification whether it
be technical elitism or any other kind
of elitism eradicated from the face of
the Earth the state does nothing because
there is no State because there is no
state
the system I advocate a resource-based
global economy is not perfect it's just
a lot better than what we have we can
never achieve perfection
thank you
the social values of our society which
has manifested In Perpetual Warfare
corruption oppressive laws social
stratification irrelevant superstitions
environmental destruction and a despotic
socially indifferent profit-oriented
ruling class
is fundamentally the result of a
collective ignorance of two of the most
basic insights humans can have about
reality
the emergent and symbiotic aspects of
natural law
the emergent nature of reality is that
all systems whether it is knowledge
Society technology philosophy or any
other creation will when uninhibited
undergo fluid Perpetual change
what we consider commonplace today such
as modern communication and
transportation would have been
unimaginable in ancient times
likewise the future will contain
Technologies realizations and social
structures that we cannot even fathom in
the present we have gone from Alchemy to
chemistry
from a geocentric Universe to a
heliocentric from believing that demons
were the cause of illness to modern
medicine
this development shows no sign of ending
and it is this awareness that aligns us
and leads us on a continuous path to
growth and progress
static empirical knowledge does not
exist rather it is the Insight of the
emergence of all systems we must
recognize
this means we must be open to new
information at all times Even If it
threatens our current belief system and
hence identities
sadly society today has failed to
recognize this and the established
institutions continue to paralyze growth
by preserving outdated social structures
simultaneously the population suffers
from a fear of change for their
conditioning assumes a static identity
in challenging one's belief system
usually results in insult and
apprehension
for being wrong is erroneously
associated with failure
when in fact to be proven wrong should
be celebrated for it is elevating
someone to a new level of understanding
furthering awareness
the fact is there is no such thing as a
smart human being for it is merely a
matter of time before their ideas are
updated changed or eradicated
and this tendency to blindly hold on to
a belief system Sheltering it from New
possibly transforming information is
nothing less than a form of intellectual
materialism
the monetary system perpetuates this
materialism not only by its
self-preserving structures but also
through the countless number of people
who have been conditioned into blindly
and thoughtlessly upholding these
structures therefore becoming
self-appointed Guardians of the status
quo
sheep which no longer need a sheepdog to
control them for they control each other
by ostracizing those who step out of the
norm
this tendency to resist change and
uphold existing institutions for the
sake of identity Comfort power and
profit is completely unsustainable and
will only produce further imbalance
fragmentation Distortion and invariably
destruction
[Music]
it's time to change
from hunters and gatherers to the
Agricultural Revolution to the
Industrial Revolution the pattern is
clear it is time for a new social system
which reflects the understandings we
have today
the monetary system is a product of a
period of time where scarcity was a
reality
now with the age of Technology it is no
longer relevant to society
gone with the aberrant Behavior it
manifests
likewise dominant World Views such as
theistic religion operate with the same
social irrelevancy
Islam Christianity Judaism Hinduism and
all of the others exist as barriers to
personal and social growth
for each group perpetuates a closed
worldview and this finite understanding
that they acknowledge is simply not
possible in an emergent universe
[Music]
yet religion has succeeded in shutting
down the awareness of this emergence by
instilling the psychological Distortion
of faith upon its followers where logic
and new information is rejected in favor
of traditionalized outdated beliefs
the concept of God
is really a method of accounting for the
nature of things in the early days
people didn't know enough about how
things formed how nature worked so they
invented their own little stories
and they made God
in their own image
a guy that gets angry
when people don't behave right he
creates floods and earthquakes
they say it's an act of God
a cursory glance at the suppressed
history of religion reveals that even
the foundational myths themselves are
emergent culminations developed through
influence over time for example a
cardinal doctrine of the Christian faith
is the death and resurrection of Christ
this notion is so important that the
Bible itself States and if Christ be not
risen then is our preaching vein and
your faith is also vain
yet it is very difficult to take this
account literally for not only is there
no primary source denoting the
supernatural event in secular history
awareness of the enormous number of
pre-christian Saviors who also died and
were resurrected immediately puts the
story in mythological territory by
association
early church figures such as tertullian
went to Great Lengths to break these
associations even claiming that the
devil caused the similarities to occur
stating in the second century the devil
whose business is to pervert the truth
mimics the exact circumstance of the
Divine sacraments he baptizes his
Believers and Promises forgiveness of
sins he celebrates the ablation of bread
and brings in the symbol of the
Resurrection
let us therefore acknowledge the
craftiness of the devil who copied
certain things of those that be divine
what is truly sad however is that when
we cease the idea that the stories from
Christianity Judaism Islam and all the
others are literal history
and accept them for what they really are
which are purely allegorical Expressions
derived from many faiths
we see that all religions share a common
thread
and it is this unifying imperative that
needs to be recognized and appreciated
religious belief has caused more
fragmentation and conflict than any
other ideology
Christianity alone has 34 000 different
subgroups
the Bible is subject to interpretation
when you read it you say I Think Jesus
meant this I think job meant that oh no
he meant this so you have to lose in The
Seventh-Day Adventist the Catholic and a
church divises is no church at all
and a church divided there's no church
at all
and this point on division which is a
trademark of all theistic religions
brings us to our second failure of
awareness the false Assumption of
Separation through the rejection of the
symbiotic relationship of life
apart from the understanding that all
natural systems are emergent where all
Notions of reality will be constantly
developed altered and even eradicated
we must also understand that all systems
are in fact invented fragments merely
for the sake of conversation for there
is no such thing as Independence in
nature
the whole of nature is a unified system
of interdependent variables each a cause
and a reaction existing only as a
concentrated whole
you don't see the plug connected to the
environment so it looks like we're free
wandering around take the auction away
we all die immediately take plant life
away we die and without the sun all the
plants die so we are connected we really
must take into account the totality this
isn't just a Human Experience on this
planet this is a total experience and we
know we can't survive without plants and
animals we know we can't survive without
the four elements you know and so when
are we going to really start taking that
into account that's what it is to be
successful success depends on how well
we relate to everything around us
I'm very aware of the fact that my
grandson cannot possibly hope to inherit
a sustainable peaceful stable socially
just World unless every child today
growing up in Ethiopia in Indonesia in
Bolivia and Palestine and Israel also
has that same expectation
you got to take care of the whole
Community or you're going to have
serious problems and now we have to see
that the whole world is the community
and we must all take care of each other
that way and it's not just a community
of human beings it's a community of
plants and animals and elements and we
really need to understand that that's
what's going to bring us joy to and
pleasure that's what's missing in our
lives right now we can call it
spirituality but the fact of the matter
is Joy comes from that Bliss of
connectedness that's our God Spirit
that's that side of ourselves that
really feels it and you can feel it deep
inside you it's this amazing wonderful
feeling and you know it when you get it
you don't get it from money
get it from connection
now if that isn't a hazard to this
country
nuclear weapons you know
what's going to happen to the arms
industry when we realize we're all one
it's gonna [__] up the economy
anyway
economy that's fake anyway the economy
that's fake anyway the economy that's
fake anyway which would be a real bummer
and see why the government's cracking
down
on the idea of experiencing
unconditional love
once we understand that the Integrity of
our personal existences are completely
dependent on the Integrity of everything
else in our world we have truly
understood the meaning of unconditional
love
for love is extensionality and seeing
everything is you and you as everything
can have no conditionalities four in
fact we are all Everything at Once if
it's true that we're all from the center
of a star every atom and each of us from
the center of a star then we're all the
same thing even a Coke machine or a
cigarette butt in the Street in Buffalo
is made out of atoms that came from a
star they've all been recycled thousands
of times as have you and I and therefore
it's only me out there so what is there
to be afraid of what is there that needs
Solace seeking nothing there's nothing
to be afraid of because it's all us the
trouble is we have been separated by
being born and given a name and an
identity and being individuated we've
been separated from the Oneness and
that's what religion exploits that
people have this yearning to be part of
the overall one again so they exploit
that they call it God they say he has
rules and I think it's cruel I think you
can do it absent religion
foreign
[Music]
it's time to claim the unity our
outmoded social systems have broken
apart and worked together to create a
sustainable Global Society where
everyone is taken care of and everyone
is truly free
your personal beliefs whatever they may
be are meaningless when it comes to the
necessities of life every human being is
born naked needing warmth Food Water
Shelter everything else is auxiliary
therefore the most important issue at
hand is the intelligent management of
the Earth's resources
this can never be accomplished in a
monetary system for the pursuit of
profit is the pursuit of self-interest
and therefore imbalance is inherent
simultaneously politicians are useless
for our true problems in life are
technical not political
furthermore ideologies that separate
Humanity such as religion need strong
reflection in the community in regard to
its value purpose and social relevancy
hopefully Through Time religion will
lose its materialism and basis in
Superstition and move into the useful
field of philosophy
the fact is society today is backwards
with politicians constantly talking
about protection and security rather
than creation unity and progress
the U.S alone now spends about 500
billion dollars annually on defense that
is enough to send every High School
senior in America to a four-year College
in the 1940s the Manhattan Project
produced the first true weapon of mass
destruction this program employed a
hundred and thirty thousand people at an
extreme Financial cost
imagine what our life would be like
today if that group of scientists
instead of working on a way of killing
people worked on a way to create a
self-sustaining abundant world
life today would be very very different
if that was their goal
instead of weapons of mass destruction
it is time to unleash something much
more powerful
Weapons of Mass creation
our true Divinity is in our ability to
create and armed with the understanding
of the symbiotic connections of Life
while being Guided by the emergent
nature of reality there is nothing we
cannot do or accomplish
of course we Face strong barriers in the
form of established power structures
that refuse to change
at the heart of these structures is the
monetary system as explained earlier the
fractional Reserve policy is a form of
slavery through debt where it is
literally impossible for society to be
free in turn free market capitalism in
the form of free trade uses debt to
imprison the world and manipulate
countries into subservience to a handful
of large business and political powers
apart from these obvious amoralities the
system itself is based on competition
which immediately destroys the
possibility of large-scale
collaborations for the common good hence
paralyzing any attempt at true Global
sustainability
these financial and corporate structures
are now Obsolete and they must be
outgrown
of course we cannot be naive enough to
think that the business and financial
lead are going to subscribe to this idea
but they will lose power and control
therefore peaceful yet highly strategic
action must be taken
the most powerful course of action is
simple
we have to alter our Behavior to force
the power structure to the will of the
people
we must stop supporting the system
the only way the establishment will
change is by our refusal to participate
while continuously acknowledging its
endless flaws and Corruptions
they're not going to give up the
monetary system because of our designs
of what we'd recommend the system has to
fail and people have to lose confidence
in their elected leaders that will be a
major turning point if the Venus Project
is offered as a possible alternative if
not I fear the consequences the trends
now indicate that our country is going
bankrupt the probability is our country
will move toward a military dictatorship
to prevent riots and complete social
breakdown once the U.S breaks down all
the other cultures will undergo similar
things
as of now the world financial system is
on the brink of collapse due to its own
shortcomings the Comptroller of currency
stated in 2003 that the interest on the
U.S national debt will not be affordable
in less than 10 years this theoretically
means total bankruptcy for the U.S
economy and its implications for the
world are immense in turn the fractional
reserve-based monetary system is
reaching its theoretical limits of
expansion and the banking failures you
are seeing are just the beginning
this is why inflation is skyrocketing
all debt is at record levels and the
government and fed are hemorrhaging new
money to bail out the corrupt system
for the only way to keep the banks going
is by making more money the only way to
make more money is to create more debt
and inflation it is simply a matter of
time before the tables turn and there
was no one willing to take new loans
while defaults grow as people are unable
to afford their current loans then the
expansion of money will stop and
contraction will begin on a scale never
before seen ending a century-long
pyramid scheme this has already begun
therefore we need to expose this
financial failure for what it is using
this weakness to our advantage here are
some suggestions expose the banking
fraud Citibank JPMorgan Chase and Bank
of America are the most powerful
controllers within the corrupt Federal
Reserve System
it's time to boycott these institutions
if you have a bank account or a credit
card with any of them move your money to
another bank if you have a mortgage
refinance with another bank if you own
their stock sell it if you work for them
quit this gesture will Express contempt
for the true Powers behind the private
banking cartel known as the Federal
Reserve and create awareness about the
fraud of the banking system itself
two turn off the TV news visit the
emerging Independent News agencies on
the internet for your information CNN
NBC ABC Fox and all the others present
all news pre-filtered to maintain the
status quo with four corporations owning
all major media Outlets objective
information is impossible this is the
true beauty of the internet and the
establishment has been losing control
because of this free flow of information
we must protect the internet at all
times as it is truly Our Savior right
now
three don't ever allow yourself your
family or anyone you know to ever join
the military
this is an obsolete institution now used
exclusively for maintaining an
establishment that is no longer relevant
U.S soldiers in Iraq work for U.S
corporations not the people propaganda
forces us to believe that war is natural
and the military is an honorable
Institution
well if war is natural why are there 18
suicides every single day by American
veterans who have post-traumatic stress
disorder
if our military men and women are so
honored why is it that 25 percent of the
American homeless population are
veterans
four stop supporting the energy
companies if you live in a detached
house get off the grid investigate every
means of making your home
self-sustainable with clean energy solar
wind and other renewable energies are
now affordable consumer realities and
considering the never-ending rising cost
of traditional energies it will likely
be a cheaper investment over time if you
drive get the smallest car you can and
consider using one of the many
conversion technologies that can enable
your car to be a hybrid electric or run
on anything other than establishment
fuels
5. reject the political system the
illusion of democracy is an insult to
our intelligence in a monetary system
there is no such thing as a true
democracy and there never was we have
two political parties owned by the same
set of corporate lobbyists they are
placed in their positions by the
corporations with popularity
artificially projected by their media in
a system of inherent corruption the
change of personnel every couple of
years has very little relevance
instead of pretending that the political
game has any true meaning Focus your
energy on how to transcend this failed
system
six join the movement
go to the zeitgeistmovement.com and help
us create the largest mass movement for
social change the world has ever seen we
must mobilize and educate everyone about
the inherent Corruption of our current
world system along with the only true
sustainable solution
declaring all the natural resources on
the planet as common Heritage to all
people
while informing everyone as to the true
state of technology and how we can all
be free if the world works together
rather than fights
the choice lies with you you can
continue to be a slave to the financial
system and watch The Continuous Wars
depressions and Injustice across the
globe while placating yourself with vain
entertainment and materialistic garbage
or you can focus your energy on true
meaningful lasting holistic change which
actually has the realistic ability to
support and free all humans with no one
left behind
but in the end the most relevant change
must occur first inside of you
the real Revolution is the revolution of
consciousness
and each one of us first needs to
eliminate the divisionary materialistic
noise we have been conditioned to think
is true
while discovering amplifying and
aligning with the signal coming from our
true empirical Oneness
it is up to you
what we are trying
you know all these discussions and talks
here
is to see if we cannot radically bring
about a transformation of the Mind
not accept things as they are
and to understand it to go into it to
examine it give your heart and your mind
with everybody think that you have to
find out a way of living differently
but that depends on you and not somebody
else
because in this there is no teacher no
pupil
there's no leader
there's no guru
there's no master no savior you yourself
are the teacher and the people you're
the master you are the guru you are the
leader you are everything
man
to understand
is to transform bodies
here
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
foreign
all right
[Music]
[Applause]